so like i kind of want to talk about the
opening party of geeks plus because
that was probably the most extra
business party i've ever been to oh my
god
so sad yes so connor wasn't there
connor wasn't there because he was he
was he was at the crunchyroll anime
awards yeah so he was
there was about like 10 ipads scattered
around this entire life
three three ipads okay three ipads
whatever scattered around this like
two-star michelin restaurant what was
the restaurant that he was like
anyway it's owned by carlos yeah yeah so
i didn't know that kadukawa owned
so many things outside of just like
anime and
manga yeah yeah and so we were at this
two-star michelin restaurant and
connor had to join us via skype or zoom
or whatever you were using it's like a
stupid time for you right
like [ __ ] like face was like this it
was like yeah like 10
11 p.m or something yeah yeah yeah and
then i never had to do a speech
and it was like the most [ __ ] awful
scene i remember like you were like
in the [ __ ] hotel room like like a
downward like because
i was like it's like
yeah he said it all in japanese and i
was like
wow no nobody nope
[Music]
they're so this is like there are a lot
of important people at this party like
how many people are there maybe like
50 plus right yeah 50 plus basically it
was like there was like mr caterpillar
was there
yeah um there was like pretty much any
anime company my anime was
the ceo of my anime list was there i
didn't i didn't even know that he was
japanese you know
danny chu was there yeah yeah yeah yeah
basically like
any company that is like in japan any
big company there was a representative
for
that company there this is like the
biggest dick energy i've ever been yeah
on a night so i remember we had to
we had to do a speech in front of all
these important people
and i remember um the ceo of
geeksplus um like kind of
he introduced us to like make our speech
and i was i was like [ __ ] [ __ ]
myself
because man i could see you as [ __ ] i
was [ __ ] myself because i had to
talk in front of all these [ __ ]
people
and i couldn't speak a lick of japanese
so i had to just like
i had to speak in english but i remember
that he introduced us and i remember
hearing something like
oh the heroes of anime
and i turned to joey i turned to joey
and i i know
and i was like um my japanese isn't like
the greatest but did he just call us the
heroes of anime for western anime fans
and joey was just like
yeah yeah and i was just thinking about
thinking to myself
why would he lie like that the heroes
like i was just like doing the blinking
meals like
i'm sorry fair though like i would say
it's kind of true
like there's a lot of people that i know
there's a lot
there's a lot of people who disagree
with that and i'm not sure why
a lot of people call us the villains of
anime anything right
some people probably who are like in the
middle of nowhere that have no anime
friends and they're getting bullied for
it and they're like oh these people are
like anime and they're actually cool
they punch them back like anime is not a
lame thing
yeah you're cool i know all i remember
was like i was i was suited up sydney
was suited up and then
like jerry rocks up in [ __ ] uh i
can't remember what you were wearing
wasn't a jojo shirt
like eddie and like shorts and i was
like
and i looked at like i looked at gaunt
like so properly dressed as like collar
shirt and everything sydney was in like
this really nice dress and i'm just
there with like my
jeans and like [ __ ] sneakers
i don't think that anyone understood
what i actually said in my speech you're
the only one who
anyone could understand yeah i mean a
lot of them did
yeah because you started speaking and
the speakers just weren't on
so all we could see was
it was an amazing speech it was such a
good speech what was more hilarious was
just not only just not
conor's speakers not being on but just
50 japanese businessmen just like really
seriously just looking down at the ipad
just being like
you're paying attention yeah you have to
bear in
i can't see anything like i'm just
talking into a webcam like
i don't see [ __ ] so as far as i know
like i'm just talking in the [ __ ]
void over here for my shitty japanese
boku no name
[Music]
oh my god that was really funny yeah but
no that was like a
really interesting experience for me
because that was like a
holy [ __ ] moment have i made it is this
the point we met some really [ __ ]
cool people there yeah yeah
who was like yeah which i did it was
like stood out the most or which company
did you like freak out over it i was so
i mean it was there yeah i mean
obviously like you know the sean and
jump
guys were there yeah but i think the the
coolest one because just because it just
kind of came out of nowhere was i think
i was talking to the sean and jump
people
and they were like what like what what
manga do you like
like what are you interested in
obviously i laid out a bunch of shin and
jump stuff and then one of the guys was
like oh well like what about stuff
that's not shown a jump like i'm just
genuinely curious
right and i think i said berserk because
i [ __ ] love berserk
and then literally the moment after i
said berserk some guy tapped me on the
shoulder and was like hi i'm the
publisher for berserk
i was like the editor
has like things like dusty he's like
i've never done that i've been hired for
five years and i haven't done anything
i've never even met mira in my life
no and and so i he he said that and i
read the card i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah that
is like the publication of berserk yeah
and i just said like
um not to be rude what the [ __ ] is mira
doing
what is he doing what's going on what's
going on what's going on with that
what's up
let's jump right into it like you
publish like you're his publisher right
like yeah
what just give me the details what's
going on yeah what's he doing and he's
like oh no he's working hard don't worry
i'm like
yeah that's what they all say idol
master in the background
i'm working hard i'm working hard i'm
working hard you're winning son
yeah no but that was really cool danny
chu was really cool danny he was one
because like i think
it's safe to say that danny chu is one
of those people who
really put anime just like weeb culture
in the west just like on the map because
i i think i think it's not too much of a
stretch to say that without danny choo's
influence
i don't think any of us would really
even be interested in japanese culture
no no
he did so much for not only like our
culture but our industry as well because
he was one of the first like foreigners
who moved to japan and really put a
highlight on a lot of things going on in
the japanese industry
yeah exactly because before i remember
it was just like japan was just kind of
a black hole
nobody knew [ __ ] that was like what that
was happening in japan we just got anime
somehow
but he actually like spotlighted a lot
of the things going on and
if not for him i probably wouldn't even
have even considered moving to japan or
you know have any interest in the
industry itself great like motivational
speeches at a lot of events like anime
expo
yeah and he's a really down-to-earth guy
so humble yeah
incredibly incredible considering
everything he's done he's like so humble
and so downtown
she showed up with his doll yeah yeah he
showed up with his smartphone oh yeah
that was so cool
yeah but you should have been there bro